يعمل هؤلاء الجنود الاوكرانيون على ازاله
الالغام في هذه المنطقه في ميكو لايف بعد
ان تم تحريرها من الروس لم يبقى الا ثلاث
بلدات على الجيش الاوكراني استعادتها في
شبه جزيره كينتريسكا لتحرير منطقه بالكامل
حسب حاكم المنطقه المتحدثه باسم القياده
الجنوبيه للجيش الاوكراني قالت ان العمليه
العسكريه ما زالت جاريه فيها استعاده هذه
المنطقه تشكل انتصارا مهما لكيف وخساره
لموسكو التي خسرت خرسون المنطقه الوحيده
التي كانت في حوزتها في هذه الحرب القصف
الروسي وما زال مستمر في ذا فوريجيا هذه
المره استهدف نقاط توزيع الغذاء في مدينه
احدى العاملات على توزيع الاغذيه
تعرضنا لوحدنا 81 في اليوم السابق اغلب
واستهدف اماكن السكنيه لحسن الحظ لم يقتل
احد تحاول الاوكرانيه
خوفا من كارثه بشريه محلول الشتاء في ظل
ازمه حاده يعاني منها قطاع الطاقه على
مستوى المحروقات والكهرباء حجم الاضرار
هائل بعد كل هجوم صاروخين واسع نطاق نحتاج
الى بعض الوقت لاعاده الطاقه لمعظم
المستهلكيها وتجديد القدره على تجديد
بالكهرباء عبر الشبكه حاكم منطقه سباته
بول الاداريه التابعه لروسيا في القرن قال
ان المنطقه تتعرضت لهجوم بثلاث طائرات
مسيرات استهدفت محطه الكهرباء وتم اسقاطه
اثنتين منها فيما كانت القوات الروسيه في
حالهم المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
والمتحدث باسم الكريم بقصف روسيا على محطه
النوويه وحذرها مجددا من خطوره الوضع